do you notice that a lot of youtubers
kind of like this triple threat not only
are they creative not only are they sort
of content creators in terms of putting
stuff up but they're also their own like
marketing PR yeah seems like they're all
all in one yeah yeah you can approach
those so many levels and it pays off it
plays up because you know again all
youtubers in this film or super prepared
and showed up on set and you know it was
just joy seeing stuff the date delivered
in the editing room and then on the
other hand a trailer comes up they let
their people know and all of a sudden
without a dollar spent you have all
these views and people know about it so
that's you know there there's also that
and along the roadside has what over
200,000 I think we me across 270 Wow
yeah welcome two months and how long is
the trailer been on two months we posted
on the fabric first oh ok now like
almost 2,000 likes and almost 500
comments wow I sounds like things are
working I follow this thing ya know yeah
and this is only 12 of them a posting
about it to the channel and I think one
or three tweeted about so you know we
still have wants to go as far as all of
them announcer to their audiences and
then linking them and we do some behind
the scenes and just kind of you know
getting the word out so your advice to
other independent filmmakers look at
youtube for casting first in addition
there's bits yeah it's a great great
it's like I don't know I compared with
you know 19th century saw to France sort
of all this whole community painting all
these little things people are doing
these crazy things but people pick up on
it in you know next century you know
they're really in so many ways they're
advanced I got sucked in all the
programs and I one of those subscribers
now and I don't see why why wouldn't you
go to them
for forecasting
you